¿Y la esposa de su hermano?
El miraron.
Señor Rice, ¿y mientras estaba en el bosque, dónde vivía? ¿Dónde dormía?
Dentro de la tierra.
Sin techo.
¿Con los partisanos?
No.
Ellos quisieron que nosotros vámonos con ellos.
No podía dejar a mi señora.
Pero mi señora, por lo tanto, no se le dio.
Ella no podía aguantar.
Como yo tenía trescientos obreros,
¿sabes? De la ciudad de Alemania,
me escapó de allá.
Con mi hermano, con mi señora.
Y entró un obrero, se llamaba Kosak, más pobre que ese.
¿Cómo se reencontró con su esposa?
Yo te digo.
Como yo he estado con ellos aquí en el bosque,
y Watzek estaba, me dijo que su señora está en mi casa de padre, abajo de la cama, escondida.
¿Y fue a buscarla allá?
Sí.
Ya estaban todos, ya enteraron todos que mataron.
Ya no eran alemanes allá.
Pues ya sabían que ya estaba liquidado mi tienda.
Y me mandaron tres días para mi pueblo.
Y un señor, pobre muchacho, se llamaba Kosak,
y su doble teta, Schitt se llamaba.
Casas allá, en Suecia.
Y su doble, allá estaban cuatro meses.
Y este pobre polaco se venía con poquito comida con nosotros.
¿En dónde era esa casa? ¿En qué ciudad?
Bietista, Bietista.
Bietista.
Todavía estaba como 500 metros de mi molino.
Al frente de mi molino, tengo foto, ¿no? Hay cementerio.
Yo estaba siete días con mi señora en ese cementerio, sin beber agua.
Estuvo primero cuatro meses en esa casa.
Sí.
¿Cómo fueron esos cuatro meses?
¿Cómo te puedo explicar?
Santo Yaacov mandó a sus hijos.
Usted, ¿cómo fueron esos cuatro meses?
¡Hambre! ¡Miseria!
Más grande puede ser.
¿Y su hermano estaba con usted?
Sí.
¿Solo?
¡Miseria! ¡Quedarla! ¡Miseria!
¿Dónde dormían? ¿Cómo dormían?
Un poquito de paja abajo. Allá sí tenía un poquito de paja abajo.
¿Y conversaban entre ustedes?
¿Cómo se puede hablar?
Todo mudo. Cosas así.
Oye, para no oír. Vecinos.
Y este hombre se arriesgó su vida.
¿Y después de esos cuatro meses qué pasó? ¿Por qué se fueron de allí?
Pues ya no podía más contar. Él ya no podía más.
Ya no podía más.
Se bufaron de una señora que se llamaba Polka.
¿Pero el cementerio cuándo fue? ¿Antes o después?
Siete días. Después de allá. Estaban siete días.
¿Y dónde durmieron en el cementerio?
En el cementerio. En la tierra.
Allá la vieron mis hijas. La vieron.
Mis hijas la vieron allá.
Miseriana Molina aquí. Aquí camino. Aquí va el cementerio.
Diez metros. Siete días.
¿Y qué hacían? ¿Cómo se escondían durante el día?
Allá. Mira. Acostada. Mira.
No podía levantar la cabeza.
¿Usted, su esposa y su hermano?
Sí.
¿Y qué comían?
Era el tiempo de trigo.
Y las noches me salieron. Cogieron zangues.
Cogón. Weiz.
Las picos que es donde crece el trigo.
Me quitaron y ese trigo.
Con esto se bebía.
Era el tiempo de esto.
¿Después del cementerio dónde fue?
Eso me fueron para una señora. Se llamaba Polka.
Ellos regresaron de la revolución de Rusia.
Papá de ella.
Era el tiempo cuando mi papá
vino de 1905
de la primera guerra de Japón.
Entonces papá de ella hizo algo malo.
¿Cómo se dice que hizo algo malo?
Que tenía que matar.
Estaba en el tribunal y juzgaba.
Con mi papá hablaba bien ruso
y se paró a hablar
y dijo,
el libro va a mirar.
Respetaron yo a mi hermano
con mi señora allá
y dijo, el papá de Polka se llamaba
Jarmaszuk.
Usted hijo de Samuel.
Sí que papá salvó usted la vida.
Entonces todo en polaco.
Sí, es verdad.
Damos la vida por usted.
Estábamos allá
y ya vino
noviembre, diciembre.
También se cansó de nosotros.
Entonces
mandaron partizanos
conocidos de allá
que nos susten a nosotros
que vamos de allá.
Yo tenía
un polaco
se llamaba Masech
que él mató
a mi familia siete personas.
Era un trabajador
un jefe de trabajadores.
Yo solo
me fui para allá en la noche
cuando dijeron que vámonos de acá
que aquí nos vamos a matar
y en febrero
adonde más grande invierno
con nieve, así miren.
Sustó.
Sí.
Llevo la casa
doy vida por ti.
Él no sabía que mi señora vive
y tengo un hermano.
Yo tengo mi señora
y tengo mi hermana quedada.
¿Por qué?
Y ahorita te voy a decirte por qué.
Cuando yo casó mi hija
tú estabas en Varsovia
y yo pedí a él que me preste
quinientos zlotos.
Entonces me contestó, cuando viene mi hermano
él va a hacer eso.
Y esto se quedó
agravado en mi corazón
que yo no voy a salvar, que salga donde quiera
conmigo no, tu señora sí.
Entonces yo le acusó
y dijo que dale.
Yo no puedo presentarme para otro palacios
uno de otro va a saber, estoy arriesgado.
Vócale por su parte
otro, tal hombre Bruchijas
y me dijo, contestó así
Que existe otro mundo
este mundo no vale nada.
Que no existe
otro mundo, dos veces no vale nada.
Yo no tengo más fuerza a luchar.
Se quedó allá
y mataron a él.